Katy Perry and Orlando Bloom gets  serious with a romantic vacay only et  has the pics Katy and Orlando  vacationing together on the island of  Kauai the couple look super cozy as they  head to dinner seems like things are  getting serious here  Katty all dressed up and Orlando looking  dapper in what else a Hawaiian shirt the  pair also kept things active going on a  hike together a popular outing in the  area and we can tell you the one they  picked can be a pretty demanding Trek  Katy limbered up Orlando even got  shirtless at one point yeah with that  bad  we don't think bloom had a problem  tackling the hike and adorably the pair  were even seen holding hands at one  point ah love now if only we could see a  smooch  to kick it  you